"Musique Douce"
"Bruit de pet"
Tu l'as eu?
"Bruit de sonnette"
Salut,
c'est la routine.
Vous permettez?
Faites comme si je n'étais pas là.
"Bruit de sonnette"
Salut,
c'est la rupture.
"Musique triste"
Salut, c'est la superstition.
Si tu arrêtes de te ronger les ongles,
il va revenir.
Salut, c'est la déprime,
et je suis venue avec une copine.
Salut!
Salut, c'est la paranoïa.
Là, il est à Ibiza
en train de baiser des putes.
Salut, c'est l'auto-persuasion,
tu es superbe,
il ne te mérite pas.
Salut, c'est la colère,
Encu** de fils de P***
de ta Mère !
Salut, c'est la culpabilité,
t'es vraiment qu'une merde.
Salut, c'est la mélancolie.
Allez, on se la remet!
Salut!
Vous êtes qui?
-Tes souvenirs!
Ça te revient là?
Décroche, Décroche.
Décroche !
Salut.
T'as pas couché avec quelqu'un
pendant qu'on était séparés?
Non.
On peut savoir qui c'est ?!